Jeff D'Andria: Cool. So from the top.
Jeff D'Andria: Alright.
Jeff D'Andria: So… and you probably haven't aligned this resume yet to that role, I'm gonna guess. Like, totally.
Stephanie Fayette: No, that was, like, from, like, last… last year. Like, I had… or, like, more like 2 years ago.
Jeff D'Andria: Got you. Yeah. So let's go from the top. Can you go scroll all the way to the top?
Jeff D'Andria: Okay.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah. So… In… let's just go with that kind of top…
Jeff D'Andria: top third piece. How do you feel…
Jeff D'Andria: How do you feel, and if anyone in the room as well, I'm kind of curious, how do we feel we're using, like, the top third right now? Does it feel like…
Jeff D'Andria: This feels really good.
Jeff D'Andria: Any improvements we might be able to make here?
Jeff D'Andria: How are you feeling, Stephanie?
Stephanie Fayette: I feel like it could be smaller, because I…
Stephanie Fayette: I mean, like, it needs to fit, like, one page, because I don't think that really anyone takes the time to read, like, a three-page… three pages resume, so I feel like it could definitely be, like, aligned a little bit more.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah.
Stephanie Fayette: Like, the… this could potentially be one line, and instead of that being here, it could just be, like, a hyperlink or something?
Jeff D'Andria: I'm…
Stephanie Fayette: Yeah, I don't know, just things out here.
Jeff D'Andria: So, I'm gonna just say to be, you know, all the way in this idea of using the top third, because that's when they're the most neutral. Let's get them to a yes.
Jeff D'Andria: I think the top… the name, the email stuff is actually fine. After that, though, I think it would be just such a competitive stance to get those… to get those 3 things. Those 3 things that they're looking for. I think it was leadership,
Jeff D'Andria: Communication, and then kind of, like, organization management.
Jeff D'Andria: I'd be curious for you, Stephanie, what is an example, and it's okay, you don't have to pull from it, your experiences on the spot on this, but I would comb through your experiences right now, and say, when is, like, your top example for those three things?
Jeff D'Andria: And then let's… put that onto the top third. And,
Jeff D'Andria: Kind of a format for that would most likely be the cleanest one, having highlights.
Jeff D'Andria: So, literally having… switch education out and call it highlights.
Jeff D'Andria: And then having 3 bullets under there, one that says, Leadership, colon.
Jeff D'Andria: And then your real-life example of that.
Jeff D'Andria: And then another that says, communication?
Jeff D'Andria: Colon, and your real-life example of that.
Jeff D'Andria: Right?
Jeff D'Andria: And now… I would make the argument that you're giving the hiring manager, you're giving the recruiter.
Jeff D'Andria: you're not making them fish through the resume for those things, you're literally starting dessert with dinner. You're starting your dinner with dessert. You're starting, kind of, with the best part.
Jeff D'Andria: Does that make sense?
Stephanie Fayette: Not quite, I think I got lost somewhere.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay.
Stephanie Fayette: You said to remove the education part and something.
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, let me share my screen, do you mind?
Stephanie Fayette: Yeah, go for it.
Jeff D'Andria: Top me real quick.
Jeff D'Andria: So what I would recommend for you is something like… like this. Having, for your highlights, right?
Jeff D'Andria: And then having something like this that says, like, leadership.
Jeff D'Andria: Colon.
Jeff D'Andria: And then have this be a real-life example from your experience.
Jeff D'Andria: Of you demonstrating that you've been a leader?
Jeff D'Andria: Right? And then here, like, communication.
Jeff D'Andria: And then have, like, a real-life example of that.
Jeff D'Andria: Right?
Jeff D'Andria: Does that make… does that make sense?
Jeff D'Andria: You're on mute.
Stephanie Fayette: Yes, that makes a lot more sense. I'm more of a visual learner.
Jeff D'Andria: Sorry, I should have just done that.
Stephanie Fayette: But yeah, this makes more sense. Are you able to, like, in the end, like, share that draft with us, or is that private?
Jeff D'Andria: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, I think…
Jeff D'Andria: Nancy, would you mind pulling up…
Jeff D'Andria: Is there another link, or do you guys want me to just send this one?
Nancy Rios: I sent it to everyone in the chat, it's a PDF file. It's called, Tech Resume Guide.
Jeff D'Andria: Cool.
Sathya Narayanan: You can just make a copy of this, Jeff, if you want, like, just click on file, make a copy, and then edit, and you can just share it with everybody, but you can make the edits on it. So we keep the original for our other workshops.
Jeff D'Andria: Gotcha.
Jeff D'Andria: Okay, yeah, let's do that.
Sathya Narayanan: And this is maybe a good time to also, you know, we talked about this, right, Jeff? Like, kind of the process, right? Yeah.
Sathya Narayanan: For all students, so you are seeing
Sathya Narayanan: Jeff is, in some ways, helping Stephanie, but we should all also benefit from it in trying to understand
Sathya Narayanan: if you don't understand, ask questions. What is the thought process that's going behind,
Sathya Narayanan: kind of running inside Jeff's head, right? And to some extent, he talked about it in the context of the presentation, right? He's thinking about… look at it from… kind of have empathy for the recruiter, understand these are recruiters who are seeing hundreds of resumes.
Sathya Narayanan: And they have to kind of make choices, and he's emphasizing the first one-third, right? And he's trying to look at the job description.
Sathya Narayanan: to understand what the expectations are. Not, like, kind of read all the bullets, but kind of synthesize an essence out of it. And then he's trying to get words out of that, kind of.
Sathya Narayanan: the words represent ideas, right? It's not just copy-pasting words, like, it's not like search and replace or something. He's identifying ideas, and then he's kind of capturing it in the
Sathya Narayanan: trying to capture it in the first one-third of it. Is that a good summary, Jeff? Like, am I…
Jeff D'Andria: Yeah, thank you, Satya, for rephrasing it, and I think
Jeff D'Andria: to bounce off of you. Here's… Again, this is, like…
Jeff D'Andria: another… I'll just say another way of saying it, if you guys can see my screen.
Jeff D'Andria: For your highlights.
Jeff D'Andria: here's… here… like, if you're really trying to get to a yes, I would say, I might play around with a structure like this.
Jeff D'Andria: what's one sentence that you can use to… that says, this is me, this is your company, and the problem you're working on, and why, like, I…
Jeff D'Andria: vibe with that. Here's, like, everything about me, why I'm such a fit for that. Start off with that. How about bullet number one?
Jeff D'Andria: And then, here's the 3 things that I pulled for Stephanie. It might be leadership, communication, management. Like, here's my example of those.
Jeff D'Andria: And then…
Jeff D'Andria: punctuate with maybe just throwing that human element in there. And we're gonna work on this, of, like.
Jeff D'Andria: What do you mean by an emblem, right? For that person at Amazon I mentioned, this might be his F1. Like, something he's just in love with, super passionate.
Jeff D'Andria: Maybe someone really likes F1 over there, maybe they don't, but it just shows that I have passion, and I can drive really hard, go deep. I can pursue things really like that. So this person has vigor, this person… there's something to them, they're not just, like, a superficial person.
Jeff D'Andria: So this is, if you're not getting interviews, this is kind of a structure that I might
Jeff D'Andria: play with, and…
Jeff D'Andria: Here is some other ideas of, like, things you might swap in. I'm hearing a lot, like, from Ashby today, from recruiters, having somewhere on your resume, something about AI,
Jeff D'Andria: like an AI project section, something. But perhaps it might even be a highlight.
Jeff D'Andria: Something about AI, and then your example of it.
Jeff D'Andria: I'm hearing…
Jeff D'Andria: this today, also, with Ashby. Are you a self-learner? Is there a time that you, like, outside of class, I just got on Coursera, or I just picked up a project of my own and ran with it, because I just needed to learn it? Are you a self-learner?
Jeff D'Andria: Swap that in as a potential highlight.
Jeff D'Andria: passion project we talked about. This is something from speaking with many hiring managers over the last year, they're looking for someone that's a closer.
Jeff D'Andria: When have you…
Jeff D'Andria: Through a job, or a class project, when have you been the person that drives it across the finish line?
Jeff D'Andria: And then what if you just put that? You put closer, colon, here's when I do that, or how many times I've done that.
Jeff D'Andria: But these are the kind of things they want, and I think using that top one-third
Jeff D'Andria: To give them what they want.
Jeff D'Andria: Is the thing to try, especially if you're not getting a lot of hits right now.
Jeff D'Andria: Is that resonating? I'm just curious to see…
Jeff D'Andria: Before we go in and start crafting our own, I'm curious how this is…
Jeff D'Andria: Landing with folks, not landing, does it sound crazy? I've never heard this before, why would this guy recommend it? Like…